what is up everybody and welcome to part
five of the Google cloud API is and such
tutorial series in this video what were
me talking about is the translation API
which will translate some text to a
target text what's interesting about
this one is the some text does not need
any sort of indication of what that
language is it will just detect the
language and figure it out the target of
course you need to supply that so that's
actually pretty interesting
translation API so to do this same thing
as everything we've covered up to this
point first we need to enable it so
translation API to party on that page
I've got it enabled already but if you
don't go ahead and hit enable once
you've done that you're ready to rumble
so let's go ahead and make a new
directory search out mixer translate
example GE translate devil and then Nana
translate example dot hi this one's
going to look very similar to the last
one hopefully by now if you've been
following through all these Google cloud
API examples you're starting to see a
trend here and hopefully building your
own API will be super simple or building
your own projects and stuff off there
api's will be super simple so now let's
go from google.com we're going to import
translate then we're going to define
translate text it's going to take a
parameter of text and then it's going to
take a target I'm going to go ahead and
auto specify the target en which is for
English target has to be ISO 639 - one
language code if you need that you can
go the dots and look at languages I
think it might even have them in the
documentation possibly so I'll click
documentation one somewhere here to
apply setting the language code yeah so
hopefully oh yeah we can click this will
take us the Wikipedia page where it has
all the codes listed so 6 3 9 - 1 right
here so all of these should in theory be
supported
I think by Google cloud basically you
can use any of these as your target
translation but here I'm going to
translate unknown text to English so hmm
coming over here let's continue wonder
how many people are mad that I'm coding
Python and min translate client equals
noobest typo generally client equals
translate dot client similar to all the
other ones then we're going to say
result equals translate client translate
it's going to take two parameters text
that we want to translate Andy target
language and that's just going to be
equal to whatever the target parameter
was that we're passing there and then
this one's really basic so you can for
example that's five three four
no okay we can print we can say the text
path and then comma results and then
this will take basically dictionary so
it put actually I think the results will
be a positive is JSON or a dictionary
I think good weight dictionary since
we're dealing in this is actual Python
API anyway so that's the text then we're
going to say the translation and that
will be the result translated text in
Nice non Pepe form print detected source
lang and then again here we can say come
on rebel
detect it we're gonna need coaching
detected source language
and then now let's do some example text
so in here you can pass whatever you
want I'm going to copy and paste a one
of the comments that was made on one of
my tutorials that is not in English if I
remember - I'll put a link in the
description if I forget someone can
remind me but also just find some text
it's not in your language and feel free
to translate it to whatever you want one
thing I will say is try to not use
translate Google calm to create some non
your language test because
translate.google.com is not perfect so
but it will probably translate back and
forth I perfectly so you wouldn't want
to do that you want to use some real
another language so nice to paste that
in there whoops gone the wrong way here
and then finally I can do translate text
the text that I want to pass is example
text and this is probably not going to
work but this will be a common error
that I think people will deal with in
their world of Python so let's go ahead
and deal with it anyway so boom
okay so we've got this non ASCII
character below ball so there's a few
reasons you're going to see this one
it's always because of non ASCII
characters but it can be for a variety
of reasons in our case we need to use
Pepe I mean utf-8 just nano back into
here and at the top of here we need to
specify our coding so we're going to say
- stars - coding : utf-8 not 78 and then
the whole - door - and then what we want
to do is I'm pretty sure this still
won't work or shouldn't work let's make
sure before I get it wrong
got it okay fine I type a translation
now so I'm not going here training we
should translation
one more time looks not Nana oh dear
there we go okay so we get the text it
was passed
translation hello greetings from
Colombia excellent tutorials I wish I
could at least have Spanish subtitles
yeni I'm not sure what that should be
let's see if we can yeah no I like the
words literally yet oh okay so it's
asking for Spanish probably I think this
was meant to say espanol I don't think
to eat in espanol right there should
never be an e after that I think that's
a typo I think I don't know I'm pretty
lads a typo uh but yeah this is
converted to utf-8 of course because if
you look at the actual text it has like
the fancy letters so if we look down
here Olaf who goes here we go scientific
or else nothing new there but then yeah
even but I forget what you call that
little tilde over the end though right
that's not a proper character sometimes
looks like it's converted when we print
out here that's that yeah okay
so anyway that's the translation API
again I feel like I ran through it so
fast that maybe it's like almost like
not even cool or impressive what it's
actually really impressive right that's
not a perfect translation but it's
pretty close I'm pretty sure there's a
typo in there and that's that's the
problem anyway I also think it's pretty
cool that it you don't need to know this
the input language it just it does that
all in the background is it text what
the input language is no problem even we
can still tell us what the input
language was or what thinks it was and
all that I think that's really really
impressive
so anyways this is going to conclude at
least my first batch of Google clouds
API stuff even with just this like you
can do a lot of really cool things like
for example you can make a pretty pretty
nice travel app or something like this
right you could take pictures of signs
you don't understand or know what they
mean that could get you can detect the
text translate the text put it in your
language like it's just like there's so
many things that you can
and it's fast and it's pretty darn
accurate so anyway I'm super impressed
with this I mean the amount even if I'm
not really positive like some like at
least the natural language ap I think is
a little overpriced the translation API
makes sense on a per character basis I
think that's pretty fair pricing but
then in the vision API is definitely
fair pricing like that's a steal for
doing image processing tasks like that
so that's pretty cool so I think it
specially is like you're just trying to
come up with ideas or make apps or just
kind of prototype things this is a no
brainer like Google Cloud ap eyes are
just that's the way to go I don't like
being dependent on people's API so but
all this stuff is stuff that you could
build on your own for sure like doing
natural language processing doing
sentiment analysis doing image analysis
all these things you could build on your
own but it would it will take a while so
like it's just you like prototyping of
ideas and stuff this is really cool
anyway that's it for now I might cover
some of the other api's I'd like to do
this speech at some point not positive
when I'll do that one but I think that
one's pretty cool especially because
there's a lot of really neat things you
can do with it but for some reason the
documentation contains like no Python
they have some Python examples but I
need the documentation that's what I
really need
so anyway or not I guess not
documentation but code looks not Python
code examples basically so you go to
Google Cloud speech and then you go to
their documentation like for the other
API is they have like let's do how-to
guides trying to find it where they've
got like all the different languages
that they have like examples for they're
trying to show like a really quick
example here libraries maybe of course
yeah now Python they're there it's there
but no let's do the rest reference let's
do speech memory just trying to show you
that I'm just not getting to it but
anyway in the documentation a lot of
times they'll have like examples for
various languages but for some reason
they don't have Python in there and it's
got like JavaScript and C or something
like that but they don't have Python so
anyway that's kind of frustrating
so you kind of have to like hobble your
way through as far as I've been finding
because speech is a little different
because you have to record it encode it
send it over or even what's neat is they
also have like a streaming API where you
can literally like as you're speaking
it's trying to figure out and then it
gains confidence kind of like when you
speak into your phone or your do Google
search with the microphone how like as
you're speaking it's printing out the
text but then a lot of times it changes
the text as you continue to speak in it
like realize okay Matt this or she meant
that so that's really cool and I really
want to be able to do that because
they've got the synchronous and
asynchronous speech recognition and
stuff but like I said right now it
doesn't really seem to be the
best-documented probably because it's
also in beta the speech API is beta so I
don't know hopefully soon I can cover
that one too I'd really like to I've
kind of poked into it and I just
couldn't figure out how to do it easily
there are some like Python modules if
you want to do speech recognition there
is like Python speech recognition it
uses I don't think from Google Cloud
speech it's like a dip it's like an
older version so you could look into
that if you wanted like if you're really
wanting to get this Google speech right
now or speech recognition right now you
can look into those because there are
some stuff there and then also the other
thing is like who cloud has competitors
as ur n iBM has both of them have pretty
similar things that you can do and I
mean I'm trying to get along I don't
know if AWS has anything like these like
people api's but anyway that's it for
now questions comments concerns
suggestions requests whatever only
remember lo otherwise I will see you all
in another tutorial